[Applaudissements]
or is a lie quand vous voulez
manipulation maïza aux thèmes tata
entend pas d'elle si tu paies la langue
mais je t'aime comme ça au maryse remue
cac lâche pas mais sa plus jeune
m
matin voilà
c'est à dire qu'aucun producteur de rap
ne s'est manifesté c'est quoi ces
sucettes
bernard qu'huawei marché est un peu un
mec moi je serais allé
ghazi
malaise chez sa mère de la [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est du rap
merci pour ce
on a perdu bernarda excusez vous s'il
vous plaît alors ta grand mère
merci pour ce moment familial en tout
cas il a été dit je t'aime aussi j'ai
ton gentil y viendrons pis c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
belle chanson le rappeur et je suis
perdu dans la ville avec un bulgare a
doctor est une chatte débile
même quand ils regardent accepté
j'espère marly gomont vas-y fais la
musique parce que ça me passionne c'est
là qu'à pédaler
wespiser en live tout ça alors je
m'appelle kameni j'aime pas de la city à
tan tan tan
c'est bien mon jeu
je m'appelle kameni j'aime pas de l'as
taissy j'ai un petit village qui
s'appelle marie gomme
[Applaudissements]
arabique au mans y'a pas très tôt 75e un
voyage attend les ordres ont passé 21
faudra d'un village alors je ne sais pas
chouette cela
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que delphine un talent
incroyable parce que vous étiez alors
allez on me dit on me dit guillaume que
vous habille aussi un talent de rappeur
c'est vrai
[Musique]
qu'apple a subi 3 4 way ma gueule
c'est un morceau de mon album et si vous
lui faut payer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous n'avez pas la musique de qualité
c'est pas mon problème